We Begin the day with Mother Nature
herself now part of the Russian attack
on Ukraine when The Invasion began back
in February spring and summer and a
quick end to the war dominated talks
here in Europe and in the United States
with December about to begin the hopes
have fallen along with the temperatures
hopes for a quick end to Winter of what
we're talking about now snow was already
falling across Ukraine just as Russian
Rockets rained down destroying power and
heating facilities Russian President
Vladimir Putin using weather as a weapon
and Ukraine's allies have announced a
retaliation plan more money in addition
to more shipments of weapons here's the
head of NATO speaking today
Russia is using brutal missile and drone
attacks to leave Ukraine cold and dark
this winter
President Putin is trying to weaponize
Winter
to force ukrainians to freeze or flee
NATO allies are providing unprecedented
support
and today alas made additional pledges
to NATO's comprehensive assistant
package for Ukraine
freeze or flee DW correspondent Nick
Connelly he is in Kiev he has more on
what Ukraine wants from this NATO
meeting
well the foreign minister head Mitchell
put it very briefly clearly he said two
things Transformers and Patriot missiles
so that's Transformers part of the key
kind of crucial kit to make sure that
Ukraine's grid survives we don't really
have a power generation problem there's
still enough electricity being produced
but the big problem is bringing it to
people who need it that network has been
attacked time and time again over the
last six to eight weeks by the Russians
and that's proving to be the real kind
of crucial point now making sure that
Ukraine has the capacity to keep on
rebuilding right now we've heard from
the authorities here that they basically
have run out of spare parts and any new
repairs to the system are basically 100
dependent on kit coming from outside and
it's very difficult to get that kit on
the open market right now because
everyone is trying to get that equipment
in Ukraine is hoovering up everything it
can find and the Patriot missiles that
is NATO is basically most sophisticated
air defense system that so far hasn't
been sent to Ukraine that lots of NATO
countries have said is too complex for
Ukraine require too much training but
the ukrainians would count to that they
have proven time and time again that
they are able to pick up new tech get to
grips with it much faster than anyone
predicted and they say basically that's
the only thing that will keep Ukrainian
Sky safe and will actually make it
worthwhile rebuilding the infrastructure
without that air defense component they
say it's basically pointless trying to
keep things going here but as soon as
they repair anything the Russians will
be back with the further strike
that was DW's Connolly reporting from
Kiev I want to pull in now Brad Bogman
he's the senior director for the center
on Military and political power at the
foundation for the defense of democracy
he joins me tonight from Washington D.C
it's good to see you again Brad we heard
there from the Secretary General
um at NATO saying that Putin is
weaponizing winter we know that you
can't fire missiles at mother nature but
Ukraine could fire more missiles to
defend its own airspace from Russian
strikes is that where we're headed
thanks for the opportunity to join you
thanks for the question yeah there's no
doubt uh you know Putin has used a food
as a weapon as a war and now he's using
winter uh I think the secretary NATO
Secretary General said it right he's he
wants ukrainians without water without
electricity without heat and without
light to try to demoralize them to break
their will uh to so they stop defending
their homes against this unprovoked
Invasion and I think it's in NATO's
interests and interests of all free
people everywhere to help in Ukraine and
ensure Putin is not successful and I
think there's three ways to do that one
is uh to listen to the ukrainians and
get them what they're asking for and
what they're asking for is more air and
missile defense capabilities we've
delivered a lot we've committed to
delivering more we need to honor those
commitments and get them there ASAP we
also need to listen to their their needs
for ground Warfare right because the
more we can support the ukrainians in
their ground offensives the more that
will force Russia to divert its finite
strike assets to to the front lines
rather than Ukrainian infrastructure
electrical infrastructure and then
finally obviously the generators and
Transformers and things like that will
help I I would note in the November 23rd
announcement the Pentagon announced
we're sending 200 generators that's
great but it's a drop in the bucket and
I'm hopeful that our European allies
will will come alongside as well and
continue to send more equipment like
that and if anyone has any questions
about what's actually happening on the
battlefields I mean the statistics
coming out are in incredible the amount
of artillery shells being used now is
the highest seen in Europe since the
second world war Ukraine is using
weapons shipped mainly from the United
States and you warned on this program
last summer that the U.S does not have
an infinite Supply in weapons reserves
are we are we about to crash into a wall
here in the United States
you know my research tells me that uh
some of our uh arsenals some of our
munition supplies some of our weapon
supplies are in better shape than others
um we're taking risk in a lot of areas I
think we're always taking risks we're
taking more risks than usual we have to
balance this as the United States is
concerned against other requirements
including requirements in the Taiwan
Strait contentions related to North
Korea and even Iran
um but yeah I I do believe the United
States is in the midst of what I would
call a Munitions production capacity
crisis uh you know so we've seen about
26 of these drawdowns where we literally
have taken 26 since August of 21 uh
taking equipment from our own stores and
sent them to Ukraine I've supported
doing that but we've got to continue to
watch this but most importantly we have
to stop procuring these Munitions at the
minimal possible rate because of
insufficient funding and we need to ask
any defensive player in the United
States and frankly Europe what is the
maximum you could do now please give us
that and what do you need to double or
triple that next year I think we need to
be doing that for our own sake for
Ukraine's sake and from the United
States perspective also to ensure that
we have what's necessary to turn to
deter aggression the Taiwan Strait well
Brett maybe for our viewers you have
insight into how this works at the
Pentagon but also on Capitol Hill why is
this not happening in the U.S if the U.S
can't deliver lots of weapons then who
can
well you know we I would respectfully
say we have delivered an extraordinary
amount I'm incredibly proud of what the
United States has done since February
24th now you know 19.7 billion dollars
in security assistance since the
beginning of the body Administration uh
uh you know I would say we Ukraine would
be uh fundamentally different than it is
today if it weren't for the sport
Americans provided but I take I take the
impetus behind your question the answer
is uh I would say insufficient defense
spending and a lot of people will
immediately dismiss that as some defense
Hawk but you know if you look at the
percentage of GDP that we're spending on
defense the United States we're near
post-world War II lows if you look at a
percentage of federal spending we're
near post-world War II lows America is
not in danger going bankrupt because of
defense spending we're going we have
problems because of entitlement spending
uh and you know we were able to get away
with that for a long long time uh before
February 24th because we were engaged in
wars in Afghanistan and Iraq that we
could sustain but when you combine
what's happening in Ukraine trying to
help Ukraine defend against this
Invasion conducting the largest
modernization effort in 40 years and
preparing to deter aggression at Taiwan
Strait there's just a massive mismatch
between the defense industrial advice we
have and the one that we need we're
waking up but as usual Americans were
waking up belatedly there are reports I
saw reports this week that weapons
deliveries to Taiwan are now behind
schedule for this year in amounts
billions of dollars behind schedule is
defending Ukraine is it leaving Taiwan
suddenly very vulnerable to a Chinese
invasion
you know I don't believe in Invasion uh
of Taiwan is imminent I do worry that we
could see something before 2027 if you
look at the recent party Congress it's
clear that they're Expediting their
preparations the Pentagon just released
their annual report on the Chinese
military today uh there's lots to be
concerned in there about it they they
specifically said they're intensifying
accelerating their modernization efforts
they have the largest Navy in the world
an Air Force that's increasingly just as
good as our own and uh the pla rocket
Force they launched 135 ballistic
missiles in 2021 alone for training and
testing that's more than the rest of the
world combined so we got our we got our
hands full in Taiwan
um we're we're uh the problem is and
we're trying to get Taiwan the arms it
needs to make itself a porcupine as
we've talked about before but take the
Harpoon missile for example we said that
we are we announced in 2020 we were
going to send that to Taiwan we're not
going to complete that shipment until 20
28 it might be over by then
well that's a brief statistic as well
Brad Bowman as always we appreciate you
putting all this into context for us
valuable Insight thank you
thank you